[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: Hello, my
name is Jarek Wilkiewciz.
Welcome to "YouTube Developers
Live." We have an exciting
Halloween episode
for you today.
In the studio, I have
Owly with me.
How you doing, Owly?
MARK HOLDER: [HOOTING NOISES].
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: OK.
We have Greg Schechter.
GREG SCHECHTER: It's good to be
here as a Civil War Union
general today.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ:
Thank you, Greg.
On the Hangout, we have David
joining us from Vancouver.
How are things in Vancouver,
David?
DAVID DMYTRYSHYN: They
are very rainy.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: OK, and then
in addition to Owly, we
actually have one more person,
Mark Holder from HootSuite.
Mark, you can be official now.
MARK HOLDER: Official.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: All right.
How you doing, Mark?
MARK HOLDER: Doing very
well, doing very well.
Thanks for having me.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: Good, thank
you for coming down from
Vancouver, right?
MARK HOLDER: Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: Cool.
How long are you staying
in the Valley?
MARK HOLDER: I'm going
home tonight.
I came down yesterday, was in SF
over the weekend and early
this week, so it's been
a great trip.
Sunshine, as opposed to rain
like David's experiencing.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: Enjoying
the summer?
MARK HOLDER: Yeah, yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: All right.
So we'll talk about HootSuite
and social
media management space.
So for those of you that are not
familiar with the space, I
was thinking that perhaps we
could start with a little bit
of an introduction to what
problem you're trying to
solve, what the company does,
and then talk a little bit
about your functionality as it
relates to managing YouTube.
And then I know Greg wanted to
talk to David about some of
the technical challenges with
integration between the
HootSuite product
and YouTube API.
MARK HOLDER: Sure.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: Does
that sound OK to you?
MARK HOLDER: Sounds great.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: Cool,
so let's get started.
MARK HOLDER: Sure.
So for those that aren't aware
of HootSuite, HootSuite is a
social media management system
largely focused to companies
and brands to help them monitor
and engage with their
communities, build campaigns
around their social media
activities.
Very much heavily focused
on team collaboration.
As I mentioned, it is for brands
and large companies,
and so it really is based around
team collaboration and
enabling teams to execute on
marketing campaigns and their
social media activities.
The company was founded
back in 2008 and
launched back then.
I joined the team approximately
two years ago,
just towards the tail
end of 2010.
At that time, we were 20 to 30
employees or so, and now we're
upwards of 200, probably up
around 230, 240, so we've
experienced a lot of growth.
As far as from a user-based
standpoint, we're really close
to crossing 5 million users.
We've seen some really rapid
growth over the last couple
years especially.
We passed 1 million just about
a month after I joined the
team, so we've really
experienced some pretty quick
and rapid growth
since joining.
And essentially, it is the
leading social media
management system and platform
for enterprises out there in
existence today.
We're very much focused on,
as I mentioned, team
collaboration, but
also engagement.
Engagement is foundational to
what we do, allowing folks to
publish to multiple social
networks and social profiles,
scheduling, geotargeting,
and in addition to that,
monitoring as well, so the
ability to monitor all of the
social profiles and channels
that you're involved with.
We currently have 80% of the
Fortune 100 companies
essentially using HootSuite.
And so we've had a lot of
traction there in that space,
in the enterprise space, in
addition to our fro- and
pre-offer--
I'm sorry-- our free
and pro offering.
Our free users, we have a ton of
those and we listen to them
very closely.
We also have our pro user base,
which is primarily SMBs,
agencies, consultants, and that
sort of thing, and then
obviously, enterprises targeted
to large enterprises.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: So how
does Owl fit into that?
MARK HOLDER: Owly
is our mascot.
I'll bring him back in here.
Owly is our mascot.
The company name is HootSuite,
so what do owls do?
They hoot, so naturally an
owl became our mascot.
And here's Owly here.
jAREK WILKIEWCIZ: Is there
some sort of a Vancouver
connection or a Canadian
connection?
MARK HOLDER: Not that I'm
so much aware of.
I mean, obviously, there's
lots of owls up there.
You see them from
time to time.
I don't know the full background
story on why owls
and why HootSuite, or Hoot, but
yeah, he makes a lot of
trips with us down to South by
Southwest, events such as
this, and all over the place.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: Now one
question that I always have
about these types of
applications is from a user
standpoint, like how do you
manage all the different
platforms since they're
actually the very
different art forms?
You have Twitter with the short
message versus G+, where
you can have extensive posts.
Like what is it that you do to
make it a little simpler?
MARK HOLDER: Yes, so on the back
end in our development
team, essentially we'll build
in the infrastructure and
support to the core product
for each of
those social networks.
So whether you're publishing
a tweet to Twitter, whether
you're posting a post to
Google+, essentially it's
going to allow you to do many of
the things that you can do
from those applications
specifically, those web
applications.
So with Twitter it's limited
to 140 characters.
Obviously, with G+ that limit
doesn't exist, so you're able
to compose and do longer
messages as well as upload
images and that sort of thing.
From a monitoring standpoint,
so HootSuite is very much
stream based--
and we'll get to that in
a little bit here--
very much a stream-based
product.
And so much of what you see in
the streams is essentially
stream based and looks
very similar.
But you will see some
differences
from network to network.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: Do you find
that people re-target posts to
multiple social media
networks?
Or do they create separate posts
to take advantage of the
capabilities of the individual
different products?
I mean, I totally get the
analytics part, where you can
do things across different
platforms.
But as far as the creation of
the content, obviously, video
will be very different
than a tweet.
So to what extent can people
actually simplify their
management experience?
MARK HOLDER: I think it really
depends on what they're
targeting, what audience
or what community
that they're targeting.
A lot of times, if you're really
just posting to your
community on Twitter, those
messages are going to go
directly out to Twitter.
If you're really looking into
developing Facebook campaigns
or campaigns around Google+,
obviously you're going to post
directly to those specific
monitors or those networks.
So it really depends on what the
campaigns and the nature
of those campaigns.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: I see.
Cool, cool.
MARK HOLDER: Yeah, so
continuing, we have had a lot
of success.
As I mentioned, we're close
to 5 million users.
We've have 1.5 million messages
being sent out daily,
and that's over our web
dashboard in addition to our
mobile products.
We've had more than a billion
messages sent to date.
So obviously, our APIs are
functioning a lot of our
mobile products in the dash.
And so there's a ton of activity
and traction and
messaging going out through
those channels, all the social
profiles that we support.
You can see a list of them
here on this slide to the
right, most of the major guys
we're partnered with, as well
as our app directory, which I'll
get to, which basically
enables us to create a lot
of these partnerships and
integrations beyond the ones
that we support natively.
We're also very much focused on
localization and supporting
the different markets
and regions and
languages out there.
So we're very much
focused on being
localized to multiple languages.
And I think our community team,
led by Dave Olson, he is
very much focused on this, and
it's a big key priority for
him to really focus on
translating the dash into
multiple languages.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: Do you support
any of the regional
social media networks in
the different geos?
Or is the set pretty much
represented here on this deck?
MARK HOLDER: We do.
No, there's many.
We have to date 35
app integrations
into our app directory.
And then we have probably 10 to
15 other integrations that
are across our native
integrations, our analytics
products, and so forth.
Regarding internationally, we
have an app integration with
Orkut, that's the popular
Brazilian social network.
We also have Viadeo,
Xing from Germany.
Viadeo's from France.
We actually just released a Sina
Weibo app-- and I know
I'm pronouncing the
Weibo word wrong.
But that's a Chinese-speaking
social network, so we've
integrated with them recently.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: Cool, cool.
So how did you get into social
media management?
I know that you're
originally from
Southern California, right?
MARK HOLDER: Yes, I am from
Southern California.
I've always been very much
focused and interested in
social media ever since it
came into existence, very
interested in tech in general,
and gadgets, and
that sort of thing.
So I moved up to Vancouver
about five years ago from
Southern California,
met Ryan through--
Ryan Holmes, our CEO--
through a mutual friend.
And this was back a couple years
ago, when things were
really starting to ramp
up for HootSuite.
And he had this vision and this
idea of an app directory,
and becoming more and more a
platform, essentially, a
social media management
system.
And so at that time, that was
about a year before we
actually launched our app
directory, which YouTube was
one of our launch partners
and launch integrations.
So much of my time was really
spent reaching out to
developers, potential partners,
and just really
creating interest in the
developer communities and
ecosystem, and getting
people interested in
working with HootSuite.
We had an SDK at that time,
which we do now, and we've got
a lot of new really cool things
you can do with the SDK
since that date.
It's been two years, but we
added a lot of cool things
based on feedback we received
from developers and partners
and our users as well.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: So this is a
good segue about the product
architectures.
So you mentioned that
you have an SDK.
So the actual individual
integrations can be done by
third-party developers, or are
they all done in-house?
Like how does the split work?
MARK HOLDER: That's right.
So we originally developed the
whole app directory idea and
framework and SDK to make
it relatively easy and
straightforward for third-party
developers and
partners to build into the
HootSuite system, to actually
build custom integrations that
can be integrated into
HootSuite as streams, and
available and provide
additional value to
our user base.
Our internal Dev team is very
much focused on the core
product and some of the other
integrations that we have.
And so they can't build out 35
individual integrations and
have those available
to our user base.
So that's what the idea was
behind the app directory,
behind the SDK that supports
the app directory, is to
really get access to those
developers to have them create
some really exciting and unique
applications that can
be added to the dash.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: So was that
something that you guys
thought about from the start?
Or was it the accessibility was
added later on in the life
cycle of the product?
MARK HOLDER: I think probably
a bit later.
For me, having joined two years
ago, that was really the
first thing that I was focused
on ion working at HootSuite,
so it was new to me.
But certainly, Ryan I'm sure had
had that vision, that this
is the direction he wanted
to go, is to build, and
integrate, and get a lot of
really cool tools available
for HootSuite users.
On all of our plans-- free, pro,
and enterprise, they're
readily available to everybody,
but really to
become more of a platform and
to bring in developers and
partners and have them
building some
cool, unique things.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: So on the
integration front, if someone
is using your product, they
can basically use your
web-based interface, which is
something that hopefully we're
going to see in a little bit.
MARK HOLDER: Yes.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: And then, from
a user standpoint, are
there any APIs to, say, pool
some of the analytics
information as well?
Or is it all done through
your front end?
MARK HOLDER: So it's all
pretty much done
through the front end.
Just to kind of clarify things
here, our SDK is all about
integrations into hootsuite.com,
into the
HootSuite dashboard, and it's
entirely about that.
Our API program, which we do
have our Engagement API that's
out there and available and you
can apply for access to
that, that's all about outbound
integrations to
third-party applications and
extending a lot of the core
HootSuite engagement
functionality to those
third-party applications.
Right now, those are the only
APIs essentially that we have
out there in the wild, and I'll
provide you a link that
you can go and look into
that documentation
here in a little bit.
But yeah, that's the difference
between our API
program and SDKs.
So right now, it's our
engagement API
that currently exists.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: Cool, cool.
So should we take a look
at the product?
Is there anything else that you
wanted to cover before we
get into the demo?
MARK HOLDER: Let's
jump into it.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: All right.
Let's do it.
MARK HOLDER: How does
that sound?
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: Yeah.
Let's look at the--
MARK HOLDER: Cool.
So just before we get there,
some developer resources here.
So we have our Dev Site, and I
encourage you all to go and
take a look at that at
hootsuite.com/developers.
Also, documentation for our
SDK is basically at
hootsuite.com/de
velopers/app-directory, and
you can go there and learn more
about our SDK, and the
different kind of functions and
events that we provide and
access to basically tap into
some of the core HootSuite
functionality.
I also encourage you to take
a look a lot of the app
integrations that we have, and
obviously, the YouTube
integration, which I'll show
you here in a second.
But there's some really great
stuff there, and you can get
some great ideas for
what's possible.
And then for our engagement
API, it's
hootsuite.com/apis/engagement,
and you can learn a little bit
more about that there.
With the actual YouTube
integration, obviously, as I
mentioned, it's available
in our app directory.
You can learn more about that at
hootsuite.com/appdirectory.
And so some of the
key features--
in working with the developer,
David, on this, it
was a lot of fun.
We spent spend several months
and weeks just thinking
through what we wanted to do and
what would be some of the
key features.
We got a lot of feedback
from our users.
We had a ton of requests from
our user base on exactly what
a YouTube integration
would look like.
And so what we thought would
be valuable was the ability
obviously to search for and
view videos in the dash.
Everybody's looking to monitor
videos that are being made
about their brand or their
company, or maybe they're just
interested in owls and
they want to at owls,
cool videos of owls.
So we definitely wanted to
give users the ability to
search for and view videos
on the dash.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ:
Not cat videos?
You think owls?
MARK HOLDER: Cat videos for
sure, for sure cat videos.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: Owls
are the new cats?
MARK HOLDER: We like owls.
We like owls, but we
like cats, too.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: I think
Greg is going to
disagree with that.
GREG SCHECHTER: Well, I just
really like cat videos.
They're just so much fun.
MARK HOLDER: Cat videos
are amazing.
Cat videos are amazing.
But there's some really cute
owl videos out there, too.
So maybe we'll take a
look at those later.
So the other thing that a lot of
our users wanted to do, and
especially a lot of our brands
and companies that are
managing their YouTube profiles
on the dash, is to
view and add video comments.
There's obviously videos
that they're
publishing to their channels.
They want to be able to see what
people are saying about
those comments.
So they can view those comments,
they can address
those comments directly from
a stream, a YouTube stream
within the HootSuite dash.
Third is the ability to view
video and user details.
And that's basically just
getting insight into the
number of views, number of
comments, number of favorites
and so forth for both videos
and YouTube users.
In addition, you can
upload videos.
And this is a really
cool feature.
Obviously, it's not at the
extent that you can at
YouTube.com.
But it's really about adding a
title, adding a description,
adding whether it's public
or private, and obviously
uploading the file.
So that's another cool feature
that we added.
And in a social engagement
dashboard management system,
you certainly want the ability
to share stuff out to your
social networks to further
amplify the videos that you're
creating for your communities
and for your brand.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: So the
use case here is
you upload a video.
This is already integrated
with the API so you don't
actually have to go through
Youtube.com.
You send it over through
HootSuite.
You guys push it up to YouTube
and then to all the social
channels, so theoretically,
like 34 or whatever number
that you have.
MARK HOLDER: Yeah, 200 to 300.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: OK.
MARK HOLDER: Yeah, sure.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: Great.
MARK HOLDER: And I'll show
you how that works here.
But obviously, it needs to
make sense from a social
engagement standpoint, and I
think that's really one of the
key pieces to this
integration.
So I'm going to go ahead and
hop over to the dashboard.
And I'm going to wake
Owly up there.
There's our mascot right
there in the dash.
So I'm going to wake him up.
And here you have HootSuite.
This is the HootSuite dashboard
at hootsuite.com.
You have a number of tabs
and streams that you can
essentially manage a lot
of your activities.
And once you get the app
installed, which is available
in our app directory here, which
you see on the left side
of the dash here.
You can see here it's right
there at the top.
And once you've installed it and
added the streams, this is
what you're going to
see in your dash.
So obviously you're going
to authenticate.
You have your My Video stream,
a search stream, and your My
Subscription stream.
So once you go ahead and go
through the workflow of
actually connecting here.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: So the flow
is, you install the app into
dashboard, and then you
authorize your channel.
MARK HOLDER: That's exactly
right, yeah, your account.
And so, here's some videos
that I've created.
These are essentially test
videos, but you can see these
are videos that I've uploaded
to HootSuite.com--
or sorry, to Youtube.com.
I'm going to go ahead and
authenticate with the search
stream, and I will do the same
with My Subscriptions.
I'm going to let that stream
just load real quick.
So I've authenticated.
Let me refresh.
And for some reason that guy
is not being friendly.
And so what you have here is,
again, you have My Videos, you
have My Subscriptions.
And Search is being funny with
me right now, but she should
come back here in a second.
And so essentially, in terms of
your videos, this is where
you're able to see videos that
you have in the dash.
If I wanted to go ahead and play
this video, I can simply
and easily click the video and
play it from within the dash.
So that video's private, and
it's my video, so that's not
going to play.
And really this comes
into play when you
have the search stream.
And let me just do a little
refresh here to
get this guy going.
There we go.
So this search stream here, by
default, is bringing in the
videos with the most views.
And so you can see that if I
wanted to watch this, I think
it's pronounced "gang-yum." Is
that how you pronounce it?
I can play that directly
from the dash.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: I'm not
Korean, but I've heard that
pronunciation before.
Greg, any opinions about that?
GREG SCHECHTER: That sounded
good enough to me.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: All right.
MARK HOLDER: So you can see
this video here playing
directly within the dash.
You can obviously, as
I mentioned, view
some comments here.
So if I click this, it's going
to pop down to comments.
Now these are paginated.
As you saw there, there was,
I think, two million-plus
comments, so obviously
that's a lot of
comments to scroll through.
But you can look at the comments
for your videos.
You can add comments here.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: So
typically this is--
what's use case here?
Are you looking at
your own content?
Are you looking at competition's
content?
Like why do you care how many
comments are there on the side
video if you're a small
business or something?
MARK HOLDER: Yeah, so you have
the ability to search, and
I'll show you that in
a quick second.
But I just wanted to walk
through some the key features
with this video here.
So as I mentioned, you can view
bio information here.
So that's the number of channel
views, the number of
upload views, number of
subscribers, and so forth, in
addition to viewing the
actual video info.
So you can get--
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: So this is all
basically obtained through
the YouTube API.
MARK HOLDER: That's right.
All this data is coming through
the YouTube API and
being presented here within
the HootSuite dash.
Another thing that, as I
mentioned, you can share
videos out to social networks.
So if you simply click this
link here, that's going to
give you auto-populate, your
main compose box in HootSuite,
shrink an Owly link that's going
to go directly to that
particular YouTube video,
and I'll just
quickly show you that.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: So we have
another Owly connection.
MARK HOLDER: Another Owly.
There's lots of Owlies.
And you can see the video
here in the dash.
And then you have the ability
to publish out to all the
social networks that you have
in your HootSuite account.
So simply and easily, a few
simple clicks further amplify
those videos.
So let's click out of that.
So if I'm HootSuite, obviously
I would have
my videos here listed.
But let's just search
for username.
Let's bring in a stream of
videos for HootSuite.
So these are the videos
that I've uploaded.
If I was interested in a
competitor of ours, I could
obviously enter in a competitive
keyword and
monitor the comments and that
sort of thing there.
So here, if I'm HootSuite and
I uploaded this video, I can
go in here, and I can look at
the comments, see what people
are saying. "So cute," "Thanks
for loving Android," "So cute,
so true." Maybe there's going to
be some people in here that
have some negative comments,
and I can go in and address
those comments directly
from the dash.
So that's--
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: Do you do any
kind of sentiment analysis
on these comments?
Or is it right now up to the
user to actually decide
whether which ones
are positive,
which ones are negative?
MARK HOLDER: It's up to the
user right now, yeah.
I mean, we'd love to tap into
some more of those analytics
options and look at some
sentiment there, in really
determining what's being said
across these, especially as
you have more and more
videos that have
more and more comments.
So right now, you see a 21, 3,
41, but if your brand is
publishing videos that has
100, 200, 1000, 10,000
comments, obviously you're
going to want to get some
analysis done on those comments
so you can dive in.
So you can favorite videos
as well, right from
the dash, and share.
And then you have a My
Subscription stream, and
that's kind of more maybe some
of our more consumer users are
using that, where they're
looking at their various
subscriptions, and the videos
that are coming through for
their subscriptions.
So all the channels that they're
subscribed to, videos
are going to come through
from there.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: It could be
good for sharing also, because
they could discover a new video
that came through their
subscription and then share it
through social media, right?
MARK HOLDER: Yep.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: It's more of
a curation type of use case.
MARK HOLDER: Yes,
most definitely.
The search capabilities--
and this is great, the
stuff that YouTube
provides via the API.
Obviously, you can search by
keyword, location, and
username, but category.
So obviously we support
category.
You can search across different
categories, whether
they were added today, this
week, this month, or any time.
You can sort by relevance,
publish date, number of views,
rating, and language.
As I mentioned, we're very much
focused on supporting
different languages throughout
the world, and localization.
Obviously, you guys
have supported
probably all of them.
But you're able to tap in and
search by language as well,
and you can see that there's
a long list of languages
supported here.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: I don't think
we have them all, but
the list is growing
pretty fast.
MARK HOLDER: The list
is growing, yeah.
So it's a great feature for
people around the world.
And then the ability to upload,
as I mentioned, you
can add a title, you can add a
description, you can add tags,
select which category is
appropriate for that video,
and then set whether it's
public or private.
And obviously select the file to
upload, upload that video,
and that will be added to your
Youtube account, and you can
manage it within HootSuite,
and share them out to your
social networks also
in HootSuite.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: Cool.
That's really nice.
So I know Greg wanted to chat
a little bit more about the
technical aspects of
integration, and I know David
is still on the line.
Yes, here's David.
DAVID DMYTRYSHYN: Hello.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: So Greg, do
you have any questions about
how they did it?
GREG SCHECHTER: Yeah, so I
tried the app out myself.
And I was really impressed.
It worked really smooth, and it
was all very quick, and a
lot of features.
I'm wondering how you went about
building it, and what
languages did you
use and stuff?
DAVID DMYTRYSHYN: We used PHP.
We used the client library
that's in the Zend framework.
PHP, we just use it because it's
easy, and if I need to
get somebody to fix something,
you can always find a PHP
program somewhere.
So it's just on a typical
LAMP-type setup, MySQL with
Apache and PHP.
It's like a million other
websites, I think.
It's an app, but it's like a
little mini website, really.
GREG SCHECHTER: And now, which
APIs did you end up using?
I can recognize some of them,
but I don't know if there were
more than what I just saw.
DAVID DMYTRYSHYN: Oh, there's
a the main ones, the YouTube
one, and the HootSuite one, and
then we're using Google
Maps as well.
GREG SCHECHTER: Great, great.
So as far as the YouTube ones
go, assuming you're using the
data APIs, now are
those Version 2?
DAVID DMYTRYSHYN: Version
2, yes, yes.
Started this a long time ago.
GREG SCHECHTER: Oh,
right, right.
Did you have any challenges
when you were doing this
integration, either with YouTube
or with HootSuite?
DAVID DMYTRYSHYN: I think the
biggest challenge for me was
the rate at which the YouTube
website changed is faster than
the API changes.
So I think the big one was, it
used to be videos on YouTube
were like--
you could rate them
with stars.
And then that got switched
to like/not like.
And there was no API
points to do that.
There was no way to do it.
So it's like there's a feature
in the website that people are
wanting, but then I can't
reproduce it in the app.
There's lots of those things.
That's even more now that the
YouTube website's been
revamped again.
There's so many new things in
there that I can't support
unless I go to Version
3 of the API.
So to me, that's the biggest
challenge, is trying to--
users want certain things that
I can't do, because the API
doesn't support them yet.
GREG SCHECHTER: Sure, sure.
Yeah, that's a common
challenge.
And we try our best to make our
APIs as rich as we can,
but it's just a lot of
work, a lot for us
to accomplish there.
But overall, when you were doing
this integration, using
stuff, did you have
good experience?
Like were the parts that you
could actually get from the
API, were they easy to use,
easy to understand?
DAVID DMYTRYSHYN: Especially
when using the Zend framework,
once you install it, I think
anybody could use the API.
Not anybody, but if you gave
them little bit of
instruction, it was so easy.
GREG SCHECHTER: Oh, great.
DAVID DMYTRYSHYN: Since we've
done the YouTube app, the
YouTube app was one
of the first
apps we did for HootSuite.
We've done a whole bunch
of other ones.
We've done Flickr, Storify,
a whole bunch of things.
And you keep coming back to the
fact that the YouTube one
was definitely the richest of
all of the APIs we've used.
GREG SCHECHTER: That's
always great to hear.
DAVID DMYTRYSHYN: Pretty
much everything was
there that you needed.
Like I said, it's that lag in
between when the website is
updated and the API
is updated.
That's the only major issue.
But everybody has the
exact same issue.
But then some other people,
their APIs, they're kind of
flaky with it.
Whereas with the YouTube one,
I know I can wake up in the
morning, and it's going
to be working.
It's not going to be down
or something like that.
I think some people, some other
companies, they don't
put a priority on the
APIs very much.
It's the orphan or whatever.
It doesn't get enough
attention.
GREG SCHECHTER: Cool.
So what's next for the app?
Are you going to keep working on
it, maybe try the new APIs
in the future?
DAVID DMYTRYSHYN: What's next is
definitely we want to do a
2.0 of the app, and we're going
to use the Version 3
API, because when you look
through what YouTube website
looks like now and what our
app looks like, there's
definitely a bit of a
disconnect in there.
The app looks Version 2 API, but
the YouTube website looks
Version 3 API.
So my challenges now is the
Version 3 is experimental.
Do I start using it now and
start coding around with
Version 3 API or do I wait?
That's my big question
for you guys.
When does Version 3 go from
experimental to something that
I can really use
in production?
GREG SCHECHTER: So we just
launched it very recently.
So it'll take awhile for it to
move out of experimental.
But it's a great opportunity for
you to give us feedback on
new things that we can
add to it before we
take it out of there.
Are there any things that you
have in mind that you would
like to see in the API
in the future?
DAVID DMYTRYSHYN: As much
analytics as you can put in.
It's nice to have views, and
number of people who have
liked and disliked, and
stuff like that.
But when you go to the analytics
on the current
YouTube website, there's
geographic stuff.
There's just so much information
in there that I
don't think I have access to.
Maybe I do, I'm not
quite sure.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: In fact, we
will have our analytics
engineers on this show.
We're trying to schedule a time
slot with them, but it
will happen in the
next few weeks.
And we'll be talking about the
new analytics API that we have
also released.
It is built on the same
infrastructure as the YouTube
API V3, so they work
well together.
But in V2, analytics was
confined to the inside API,
which was a small subset
of the YouTube API V2.
Whereas, in V3, analytics is a
first-class citizen with its
own set of APIs and its
own set of metrics.
So definitely you're right that
on the website if you go
to Youtube.com, there are still
metrics that you can see
there, but they are not exposed
through the API.
But this is something
that we'll discuss.
The team is actively working on
including more and more of
these metrics into the
analytics API.
Another thing that is nice
about that one is it's
somewhat modeled upon
the YouTube--
sorry, the Google Analytics API,
so if you work with the
analytics APIs, you will
find it very familiar.
So it's more of a data cube
model, and you can issue
various queries against it.
So it's quite powerful.
So definitely we will cover
that in more detail in the
next few weeks.
So David, I hope that
you'll be watching.
DAVID DMYTRYSHYN: I'm
definitely going
to watch that one.
Everybody wants to
analyze things.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Cool.
GREG SCHECHTER: That's all
the questions I had.
Did you have anything else
you wanted to add, Jarek?
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: No, I think
you guys covered it.
So I was hoping maybe before we
wrap up for today, we could
look through our Moderator
queue--
GREG SCHECHTER: Sure, sure.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: --see if
there's anything in there that
we should address.
GREG SCHECHTER: Let
me see if there's
anything for our guests.
So the first question I see is,
they're asking if you guys
will be adding any new features
to the YouTube app
for HootSuite any time soon.
I know you just to addressed
that a little bit.
I wasn't sure if there's
anything else you wanted to
comment on.
MARK HOLDER: Yeah, we're
working through it.
As David mentioned, he's working
through and will be
looking at the V3 API and really
determining exactly
what we want to add and what
additional functionality we
want to add for the V2 of
the app integration.
We listen very closely to our
user feedback across the
board, across all
of our channels.
So we take that feedback very
seriously, and want to kind of
iterate and create a V2 based
on that feedback, and really
give the value that our users
are looking for in the V2.
So we put out the V1
about a year ago.
And we really want to get
something that's a lot more
than what you have now and
fuller and richer and deeper.
GREG SCHECHTER: Let's see
what else do we have?
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: There is one
about the implementation of
the actual app, whether it's
HTML5 or Flash, so I think
that's a question for David.
DAVID DMYTRYSHYN: It's HTML5.
It's Ajax, it's JavaScript, it's
PHP, it's HTML5, but it's
basically it's that.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: Cool.
Anything else?
GREG SCHECHTER: And then, of
course, there's the one that I
always see--
"Is YouTube and Google Developer
Relations hiring?"
The answer is, of course, yes,
and you can find job postings
on developer.google.com/jobs.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: Great.
All right, so I think this is
all the time we have today.
Thank you very much
for coming.
MARK HOLDER: Of course, thank
you guys for hosting.
JAREK WILKIEWCIZ: And have a
safe trip back to Vancouver.
And we are excited to see
this integration.
I think it's very interesting,
an interesting space.
I know it's very hot.
And again, I'll check
out API V3.
And we will send more
information about the
analytics API overview that
we'll be giving on this show
pretty soon.
Till then, I'll see you all
next week, same time,
Wednesday, 10:00 AM Pacific.
Thank you, bye.
MARK HOLDER: Thanks, bye-bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]